what was it like when you guys actually
because the stones are such a big
influence on you when you start opening
for those guys a best show is in
Montpellier in the South of France right
it was Black Crowes Bob Dylan and the
Rolling Stones
unbelievable it was the best week I'll
always remember because I'm at Bob that
day and it was a he's my you know
ultimately my my biggest hero so we're
on we're backstage I mean behind Keith
Hampson the stones had a like of Rolling
Stone was their single in Europe for
that tour when the on that Voodoo Lounge
cycle so they're they're gonna have Bob
sit in and and I'm like oh my god you
know so Mick Jagger's wearing like a
long blue satin shirt with a belt pirate
style over it and I just remember things
I don't know my social security number
but I know that stays with you
so they're like ladies and gentlemen you
know you know there's 60,000 70,000
people out there Bob Dylan and Bob comes
walking right beside me and rich and
he's wearing the exact same outfit he
like saw what me and he hit I was like
that's that's [ __ ] amazing he walks
out on stage and you know the Rolling
Stones are the Rolling Stones they're
the greatest rock and roll band of all
time right playing a Bob Dylan song Bob
sitting it those stones don't Jam they
don't deviate so it's like Dan who once
upon a time didn't you
go around to the course and then they
come up to Bob's turn so the band brings
up done a tenth down one two three four
and Bob goes in Mike and doesn't sing
anything ah and you see them look around
and they're like okay because it's kind
of like you missed the turn at a
roundabout you got to go all the way
around so they go all the way around
again one more time I'm on to it he just
leans into the mic turns away I'm like
oh my god [ __ ] it goes on for another
half a verse I mix gonna come over and
like save the day right and then Bob
finally goes to the mica did you start
singing something and they don't finish
and they're walking offstage we're
standing there and like Mick and Keith
like they go like he walks off before
the end of the song they're like Bob
Dylan
he turns around and he looks at them and
he goes [ __ ] you like this and he gives
him the finger and I'm like and Keith
don't be like that
what is [ __ ] showing it it's the
greatest thing to see we've ever seen